um I want to talk about what the world
is going through right now which is the
World Cup thank God I thought you were
great children children and separated no
no no immigration separation yeah
although politics Bobbili no it's it's
awful what's happening there and the
border it said but you know what yeah
they got one
they got one up though you know Mexico
did something people don't if you're not
well if you don't know soccer right you
have to understand that the German team
it's not that just they're just good
they have a lot of superstars on their
team like celebrities like guys that are
the best at what they do and they get
paid the most and they have just their
life in New York Yankees right they have
just killers on that team all right half
the teams from Bayern Munich the club
Arsenal has you know so they have great
talent Mexico has a couple of fading
stars but the rest of them a play in
life yeah B plays in the LA you know
team you know so M s yeah MLS MLS yes so
um but what they did was um a miracle to
hold them to a 1-0 win that's and then
them finding a you know they created an
earthquake recorded earthquake in Mexico
City when they scored courted real
seismic seismic activity in Mexico
because they celebrated so hard yeah
people are jumping up and down so hard
it's creating the earth the crack I feel
like that's what I feel like LA felt
that too because I think that you know
if you've never come to LA if you've
never been here
like it's just Mexicans and Koreans so
those are my two teams this World Cup
those two hundred dogs
the Korea loss yeah you didn't see any
seismic activity in Korea this morning
because they played like a bunch of
[ __ ] yellow monkeys I'm so ashamed of
being Korean right now you can you know
you Oh God
get it together your speed nothing but
cat did you hear about the Swedish team
sending out to their train their clothes
training sessions yeah did you hear
about yeah I know about Swedish team had
to apologize for you know basically
spends like one of their spies like
rented a home outside of like their
training facility was a tour and what
are the clock and then Korean coach goes
oh they're not gonna know anyway they
can't tell us apart yeah the coach was
like why can't why people tell us apart
is the cook the coach the coach said
we're not worried because let me say
something right now dude I'm tired of
you white [ __ ] not being able
to tell us apart do you know what I get
I get sometimes what love you're DJing I
go who do you think I am you're Steve
Aoki right there's a bigger problem
they think you're Steve Aoki there's a
bigger problem with this person no no
the problem is within you the problem is
you know it's it's like either you guys
just stare at why people your other
white people too long right you guys are
just used to but you want to come to us
you guys think that I'm like you know
other celebrities or you know I mean or
that's a compliment bother you but
you're famous look you look famous you
do look famous Wow I grab the first
famous name your head oh oh oh oh the
guy from Goonies there's an Asian gang
yeah yeah what are you talking about
I've never know I've never seen Goonies
you never saw Goonies see Josh Brolin
there's also a few movies that everyone
keeps talking about but I never Chyna we
got to roll that is what we're watching
tonight that's ridiculous of course I've
seen that made it to the Philippines I
pretty sure Goonies did - I was just I
never watched it but yeah so that's the
way they couldn't by thought they
switched jerseys - no they start
swapping players - then after that I
think the coach realized that he was
like you know what they can't even tell
us apart so who cares yeah I think you
guys that you don't get you call the
white president whoever that leads your
organization so James I'm identifying
minorities and ask them you gotta get
you know classes just memorize what okay
we yeah we have round yellow faces I
know but a lot of it a lot of it is
alright but there's a little different
like different you know that like my
nose is positioned differently on my
face just try to memorize our faces
right what's the one distinct different
feature from Bobby and Steve five four
three two one skinny fat long hair short
hair
who's that you [ __ ] [ __ ] what
an [ __ ] hearty you're Laurel and
Hardy updations yeah oh my god
[Music]